a criminal case in Springfield Illinois
could have major implications for
emergency medical care in this country
now this case involves an incident
captured in disturbing police body cam
video last month the man in the footage
His Name is Earl Moore Jr he died a
short time later and two emergency
medical workers who treated him have now
been charged with first-degree murder
Moore's family sat down with Charlie
Demar this is her first TV interview
Charlie good morning to you
good morning Gail Earl Moore Jr's mother
and sister say he was a hard-working Man
Who Loved his family they say he
struggled with alcohol but was trying to
beat his addiction we do warn you the
video you're about to see may be
disturbing
my heart hurt
because I ain't gonna never see my son
no more ever
all because
of those two people when 35 year old
Earl Moore Jr called 9-1-1 he was
looking for help but the paramedics who
were supposed to care for him are now
accused of killing him we're gonna have
an ambulance come check you out police
officers called for that ambulance on
December 18th after they were told Moore
was hallucinating due to alcohol
withdrawal this is Earl body cameras
captured Peggy Finley a paramedic with
LifeStar Ambulance Service entering the
room just a minute later when Moore
didn't respond Finley yelled at him
she then tried to drag him across the
floor
sit up now she didn't even know Earl but
she act like she knew him calling his
name and dragging him like that you're
gonna have to walk cause we ain't
carrying you so let's let's get up on
your feet because I am seriously not in
the mood for this time at one point an
officer appears to notice Finley is
agitated
when Moore finally got outside officers
helped another lifestyle paramedic Peter
cadigan put him on a stretcher cadigan
appears to shove more back down on his
stomach before both paramedics secure
the safety straps
that's the part I keep saying I keep
seeing him
slam him like that that's what I keep
saying to her whole body shake Moore
died less than an hour later after
arriving at the hospital an autopsy says
the cause was asphyxia due to prone face
down restraint Finley's lawyer told CBS
News the murder charges are an
overreaching stretch saying prosecutors
are turning what at most might be
negligence into a murder cadigan's
attorney similarly says this was a tort
not a criminal case and that his client
is devastated and called the case highly
unusual Bob Hilliard represents the
Moore family they didn't do any of what
we all know is is not only the right
thing to do but the thing that's
necessary uh to save a person I mean it
was Earl that night but who's to say who
it is the next night
is convicted cadigan and Finley could
face anywhere from 20 to 60 years in
prison life Star declined our request
for comment and the attorney
representing the more family plans on
filing a wrongful death lawsuit against
both LifeStar and the paramedics
involved later this morning Nate
Charlie thank you I'm with the attorney
that says thank goodness there is a
video you know what's so disturbing
about that is a Mr Moore had called for
help clearly he has had issues you can
you can his family would say that but
the fact that he was treated in such an
inhumane manner is very tough to us very
very tough to watch and of course being
an EMT is one of the most difficult
stressful jobs out there of course right
yes but nothing excuses that kind of
treatment of a patient yeah but girl you
said a keywords call for help help